[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and for months we have
been getting a ton of comments asking us
about our thoughts on the attack on
Titan season 2 opening and why we see a
bunch of massive animals including
dinosaurs now we didn't make a video
about this sooner because we were
waiting to form a strong theory about
the meaning of the dinosaurs and all the
other animals into season 2 opening but
now finally the time has come to reveal
anime uproars official theory on the
season 2 opening naturally we're going
to have to get into manga spoilers in
this video so proceed with extreme
caution by the way if you want to
discuss this and other anime theories on
a daily basis you can join our discord
server link in the description and if
you want to see more of these theory
type videos be sure to go jurassic mode
on that like button and if you're new to
the channel don't forget to subscribe
and hit that notification bell now I
believe that the season 2 opening might
actually give us a massive clue about
the true origins of the Titans and Titan
power and when I say true origins I mean
a completely different origin story than
the one we have been told this whole
time in this famous depiction of the
devil and Emir fritz we see Ameer
apparently receiving the secret of Titan
power from the earth devil many have
pointed out that the devil in this image
looks a lot like the JA titan leading
some to speculate that the JA titan is
related to the devil in some way while
it is possible that this mysterious
devil creature really did resemble the
JA Titan it is also worth noting that
the appearance of the jaw Titan changes
depending on the person that possesses
the power so it could also be a
coincidence that the jaw Titan of Amir
from the 104th training core looks a lot
like this devil figure but speak of the
devil
what if the earth devil didn't really
look like this at all in fact what if
this devil never existed what if the
devil is just a metaphor a symbol for
something else entirely
what if Amir Fritz didn't get the Titan
power from any magical creature at all
but instead created this power of
herself through experimenting on
humans and combining their genes with
the genes of powerful beasts in order to
create a race of superior warriors who
then allowed her to make el Dia the most
dominant nation on earth in chapter 88
we learned that Amir was able to create
the Titans because she discovered the
source of all organic material but what
does that mean exactly well what if this
means that she discovered what today we
call DNA DNA is a self-replicating
material present in nearly all living
organisms as the main constituent of
chromosomes DNA holds the genetic code
of all living things so it is a
fundamental constituent of all living
organisms the source of all organic
materials and it is the carrier of
genetic information let's keep all of
this in mind for later now we know that
humans can become Titan shifters by
consuming the spinal fluid of other
shifters and we know that the beast
Titan can use his own spinal fluid to
create mindless Titans so what is the
very first Titans were created by
injecting humans with the spinal fluid
or some other similar substance that
contains the DNA of beasts like
elephants whales and even dinosaurs and
this combining of human and animal DNA
actually created the Titan and if you
think I'm crazy in chapter 86 of the
manga grisha's father literally tells
Grisha that there LD and ancestors
believed in eugenics now historically
eugenics has referred to the idea that
people with the best genes should
procreate with each other in order to
produce the best possible offspring and
alternatively that people who allegedly
have inferior genes should not reproduce
but there is another form of eugenics
genetic engineering through genome
editing genome editing refers to the
process of DNA being inserted deleted or
replaced in the genome of a living
organism which essentially gives
scientists the power to control what
genes a person will have such as what
color their eyes will be and so on while
this technology is not yet being used on
humans it has been tested on plants and
other organisms even in our own
now imagine what could be done if human
DNA could not only be altered but also
combined with the DNA of powerful beasts
to give these humans the power agility
speed giant size and so on that these
creatures possess let's go back and look
at the second season opening more
carefully the second season opening
shows the glowing hearts of all the LD
ends and it also shows the glowing
hearts of a bunch of seemingly random
beasts such as whales elephants and even
dinosaurs you will notice that at no
point are the two members of the
Ackermann clan
Mikasa and Levi shown with their hearts
glowing only the LD ends are also all
the images of animals with glowing
hearts shows them eating each other and
this is interspersed with images of the
beast Titan and also Eren inside his
type
now I believe that the glowing hearts
represent the fact that all lVN's are
connected in chapter 88 we learned that
there are invisible paths connecting LDN
which cross at a single coordinate but
if the LD ends are all connected and
this is what the glowing hearts are
telling us then why did the hearts of
those animals including dinosaurs also
globe are they trying to tell us that
the LD ends are genetically connected
not only to each other but also to these
animals because their DNA was somehow
combined with the DNA of these animals
we know that the nine Titan shifters
have animalistic abilities the beast
Titan closely resembles an ape
jaws is like a chimpanzee but with teeth
that resemble an alligator or dinosaur
the armored Titan and other Titans can
harden their skin like some animals can
for example Turtles having hard shells
the female Titan can call other Titans
to her with a cry like many animals do
with mating calls the Colossus Titan can
grow to an enormous size like dinosaurs
or whales the cartman Titan can carry
heavy loads for long periods of time
like a mule or an elephant and so on to
further emphasize this point while we
see the images of various animals with
glowing hearts flash by in the opening
we also suddenly see this image now I
don't know about you but to me this
looks a lot like an amoeba an amoeba is
a type of cell or organ
which had the ability to alter its shape
primarily by extending and retracting
pseudopod again we are getting some
major clues here that science is the
true origins of the Titans not Devils or
magic attack on Titan has always felt as
more of a science fiction story than a
fantasy story to me closer to
Frankenstein than to Harry Potter and to
me that Titans are much closer to giant
zombies or Camaros from Full Metal
Alchemist Brotherhood than to magical
creatures in Chapter 93 of the manga we
were introduced to the term Titan
science when we learned that the power
of the Ackermann clan is a result of
quote Titan science I believe that the
members of the Ackermann clan were also
subject to genetic experimentation
except because they are not LD and the
results were different and instead of
transforming into Titans they gained
other abilities in the world of attack
on Titan we constantly see terms like
Titan chemistry and Titan science and
lVN's are not turned into Titans with
magical wands or spells but through
injection and these injections can even
control how big a Titan get special
injections can allow Titans to harden
and so on these are clear indications
that science plays a major role in the
world of attack on Titan and that this
is the work of science fiction rather
than fantasies my theory is that a mere
frit discovered the secret of DNA and
used eugenics to alter the genetic
makeup of the LDN race we know that
different ethnic groups have variations
in their genetic makeup so for example
while some ethnicities are prone to
being lactose intolerant others are not
I think that Amir found a way to combine
the DNA of LD ins with various types of
beasts in order to create LDN super
soldiers or Titans that would make Elvia
the most dominant nation in the world
since you would not have wanted other
nations to have the same power he near
made her experiments specific to the LDN
gene pool and other ethnic groups with a
different genetic makeup cannot access
the same power this means that the
random depictions of animals in the
season 2 opening are not random at all
they're a huge clue about the true
nature
and origins of titan power that no one
is supposed to figure out until the
truth is finally revealed in an upcoming
chapter of the manga now we know that
the anime has given us some surprising
who's already such as giving us the
details of Amir's backstory and that's
Amir from the 104th Training Corps much
sooner in the anime that it was revealed
in the manga and also the closing of
season two gives us a lot of clues about
the origins of the Titans and Amir frits
even though this was not yet mentioned
in the anime so these animals and
dinosaurs in the opening might very well
be another important hidden message
several important questions can be
raised here one is of course the
dinosaurs if we assume the dinosaurs in
the world of attack on Titan became
extinct before humans appeared as was
the case in our own world then how could
in your fridge use dinosaur DNA to
create Titan well as fans of Jurassic
Park will know in science fiction at
least it is possible to extract dinosaur
DNA from say an ancient mosquito that
had sucked the dinosaurs blood and then
use it for genetic experiment the other
question is how ancient aliens could be
so technologically advanced as to
discover DNA and gene splicing nearly
2,000 years in the past
one explanation could be that like the
myth of Atlantis in our own world
ancient el Dia was actually more
technologically advanced than we even
realize but the LD ins were forced to
forget above this secret technology by
the power of the founding titan another
explanation is simply that the secret
method of creating titans is heavier on
the fiction than on the science if we
look at Frankenstein first published in
1823 this book is considered one of the
first works of science fiction in the
book dr. Frankenstein discovers a
previously unknown but elemental
principle of life much like Amir
discovers the source of all organic
material and he uses chemistry and other
scientific knowledge to impart life on
nonliving matter in order to create his
famous monster the explanation we are
given for how this actually happens is
ambiguous and doesn't stand up to
scientific scrutiny but this doesn't
mean that Frankenstein is any less of an
interesting more
work of science fiction it is also worth
mentioning that the full name of the
Frankenstein book is Frankenstein or the
modern prometheus
and who was prometheus believe it or not
in Greek mythology Prometheus is
literally a Titan known as the creator
and greatest benefactor of humanity
according to one of the legends
Prometheus stole fire from the gods and
gave it to humanity to use and of course
like the power of the Titans fire can be
used as both a deadly weapon and as a
useful tool so the character of a mere
fritz can be compared to both Prometheus
the Titan and to dr. Victor Frankenstein
he plays God and gives humanity a new
miraculous invention that can be used as
both a blessing and occurs the fact that
Amir is said to have gotten the power of
the Titans from a devil is interesting
in itself as well as the fact that LDN
are said to have the blood of the devil
flowing through them in the Bible the
serpent often though not always
associated with the devil tense Adam and
Eve by promising them power that rivals
God if only they would taste the
forbidden fruit most often represented
as an apple once they do taste it Adam
and Eve are banished from the Garden of
Eden by God for attempting to make
themselves equal to him and of course
another name for the Garden of Eden is
paradise and in French
paradise is parody or parodies so what
if the devil in attack on titan is
simply a symbol or a metaphor for amir
fritz herself playing God with the
audience by experimenting on them in
order to turn them into titan blood of
the devil running through Aldi and
doesn't make sense if we think about
this in the biblical sense even though
Adam and Eve were tricked by the devil
and they are said to be the ancestors of
all human we humans don't say that the
blood of the devil runs through us
however if Amir was playing God by
literally altering the DNA of aliens
then we can say that the blood of the
devil runs through LD ends because Amir
their ancestor is the true devil in the
story my theory is that the power of the
Titans is some type of virus that
affects only LD ends because it was
designed by Amir
Ritt to react to their specific DNA a
virus is a microorganism that cannot
grow or reproduce apart from a living
cell so it needs a living host to
multiply a virus invades living cells
and uses their chemical machinery to
keep itself alive and to replicate
itself a virus has the ability to mutate
and this mutation is the reason why some
viruses change slightly in each infected
person and this could explain why the
appearances of a titan shifter change
depending on who is using the power
because the virus reacts differently to
each individual's so we can imagine
Ahmir Fritz as some sort of mad
scientist playing God and creating a
virus that reacts to the unique DNA of
LDN and turns them into Titans this
virus is inserted into LD ends to
injections or through the consumption of
the spinal fluid or a Titan and there
are a number of variations to the virus
some forms of the virus will merely turn
lVN's into pure Titans while others will
turn them into Titan shifters some forms
of the virus will create larger Titans
while others will create smaller ones
some have the ability to harden while
others do not and so on furthermore the
reason that Titan shifters die after 13
years it's not because of some curse but
because after that period of time the
virus wears out their body it exhausts
its host and it must then move on to a
new host there are some elements of
Titan power that don't correspond to any
known virus in our own world of course
and one of them is the fact that if a
Titan shifter dies without anyone taking
the power from them then the power will
pass on to an LVN baby one potential
explanation however is that if the host
dies the virus can no longer survive
inside the body so it must become
airborne and search for a new host since
babies have the weakest immune systems
and are the most susceptible to viruses
the titan shifter virus attaches itself
to an LVN baby the other element is the
power of the coordinate or the ability
of the founding titan to manipulate the
memories of LD while this power must
somehow be connected to LD and DNA
because it only affects the LD and
bloodline there is obviously no
scientific equivalent in our world
needless to say is Titan
power is the result of Amir Peretz
engaging in DNA manipulation and
creating a virus that turns lVN's into
titans this is a virus that is far
different from any that we are familiar
with in our own world but if it really
turns out that titan power is the result
of scientific experimentation and not
magic then there is hope that the so
called curse of Amir could actually be
cured with further advancements in
science and medicine meaning that our
protagonist Armand and Aron might not
have to die after all how awesome would
that be and that is our theory on the
attack on titan season 2 opening and the
true origins of titan power please feel
free to share your own thoughts and
theories in the comments below we would
love to hear from you and maybe new
theory video ideas will come out of the
comments section to this video if you
want to see more attack on titan Theory
videos like this one be sure to leave a
like and let me know in the comments
because I actually have a theory on what
the ideology on the 145th King really is
and why every member of the royal family
adopts this same ideology as soon as
they receive the founding titan power so
if you'd like to see that video be sure
to let me know in the comments and if
you're new to the channel don't forget
to subscribe and hit that notification
bill as always thank you so much for
watching and until next time see a space
cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]